este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a sus
art vp n luego os doy más detalles pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y seguro que
todos me sabréis responder cuál es el
país donde se producen más películas en
todo el mundo ya sé que lo sabéis la
respuesta no es eeuu sino la india
[Música]
exacto todos hemos oído hablar de las
películas de bollywood aunque
seguramente muy pocos las habréis visto
pero la pregunta realmente interesante
es porque las películas indias tienen
tanto éxito como es posible que
hollywood apenas haya podido entrar en
el mercado indio veréis en casi
cualquier país las películas más vistas
suelen venir de eeuu por ejemplo en
españa es muy difícil que una película
española súper en taquilla las grandes
superproducciones de hollywood y lo
mismo ocurre en casi todos los países
- en la india
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en este país
sólo el 13 por ciento de los ingresos
del cine vienen de películas extranjeras
eso incluye a las películas
estadounidenses el resto es todo
producción propia y ya sé lo que estará
pensando alguno seguramente esto se deba
a que la india es un país gigantesco el
segundo país más grande del mundo en
población verdad pues lamento deciros
que os equivocáis porque pues porque la
india puede ser muy grande es cierto
pero también tiene más de 26 idiomas
regionales de hecho cuando hablamos de
bollywood sólo nos referimos a las
películas hechas en idioma hindi pero
eso es sólo un 20% de la industria en
otro 80% va para todos esos idiomas
regionales bengalí marat y tamil y
tantos otros sin embargo pese a todo
esto sólo en el año 2019 la india
produjo más de 2.200 películas
[Música]
el cine indio es tan importante que
incluso se ha convertido en toda una
arma política mirad lo que llegó a decir
el ex primer ministro indio manmohan
singh sobre el cine indio
cuando voy a oriente medio/áfrica la
gente habla de las películas indias esto
es un nuevo modo de mostrar al mundo la
creciente importancia de la india el
poder blando es muy importante en el
nuevo mundo de la diplomacia manmohan
singh ex primer ministro de la india el
cine indio es tan influyente que bastó
una sola película para que el turismo de
la india hacia españa creciera un 9 5
por ciento en sólo un año de hecho si
algún día vais a la fiesta de la
tomatina en buñol
seguramente veréis a un montón de indios
y todo esto es por una película zindagi
na milegi dobara que habla de unos
chicos indios que hacen un viaje por
españa pero no sólo eso sabéis cuál es
el canal de youtube más grande del mundo
pues no no speed y pai este series el
canal donde se cuelgan casi todos los
videoclips de política
y no os equivoquéis el cine indio no
sólo se consume en la india de hecho
pese a las malas relaciones entre china
y la india bollywood está arrasando en
el gigante asiático pero de eso vamos a
hablar más adelante antes de seguir
quiero hacer una aclaración a diferencia
de hollywood que es un suburbio en los
ángeles donde están todas las grandes
productoras estadounidenses bollywood no
existe como tal es decir que no hay
ningún lugar llamado bollywood sin
embargo si podemos decir que casi todas
las películas producidas en idioma hindi
se producen en mumbai y poco más la
llamaba antes bombay al igual que los
ángeles mumbai es una ciudad muy
próspera muy cosmopolita y donde hay
buen tiempo todo el año por eso es aquí
donde se hacen tantísimas películas pero
ahora la pregunta es por qué el cine
indio es tan popular como afecta a la
política a esta industria y por qué los
chinos prefieren el cine de bollywood al
del mismísimo hollywood hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
si queréis ver el mejor cine de
bollywood es probable que no podáis
porque pues porque internet tiene cada
vez más restricciones geográficas
así que si queréis acceder a todos los
catálogos completos de bollywood
seguramente tengáis que utilizar una vpn
y cuál es la vpn favorita de visual
política pues ya lo sabéis todos sur
shark vpn
[Música]
usar que es una vpn fantástica y muy
segura por ejemplo nos ha pasado alguna
vez que entráis en una página web o
salen un montón de ventanitas de
publicidad pues a eso se le llama
fishing y es una táctica peligrosísima
por ahí se cuelan montones de cookies y
de virus que se meten en el móvil o en
el ordenador pues como ya sabéis cursar
tiene una herramienta que se llama clean
web que bloquea todos estos popup si
todos estos enlaces que tienen más
peligro que un saco de bombas pero no
sólo eso con la única cuenta de surf
shark
podéis registrar todos los dispositivos
que queráis el móvil la tablet el
portátil no hay ningún límite de
dispositivos
[Música]
y como siempre tenemos una oferta muy
especial para todos vosotros que seguís
visual políti básicamente si utilizáis
el código político terminado
tendréis un 63% de descuento más tres
meses extra totalmente gratis es más
podéis probar surfers durante los
primeros 30 días sin ningún compromiso
en la descripción
os dejo los enlaces y ahora sí vamos a
ver un poco de historia todo empezó con
jesucristo en el año 1911 un señor que
se llamaba dadas a hef falk fue con su
familia a ver una película sobre la vida
de jesucristo falk no era cristiano pero
recordad que el momento la india era una
colonia británica las salas de cine
estaban pensadas para los colonos
británicos sin embargo farc quedó
fascinado al ver esta película y lo
primero que le vino a la cabeza fue
hacer una película parecida pero en
lugar de contando la vida de jesucristo
contando historias de la mitología india
y como siempre decimos en visual
político dicho y hecho
falk se marchó a londres ya aprendió a
hacer películas después
volvió a la india busco el dinero y
produjo el primer film indio de la
historia rah a heart y sangre se trataba
de una película muda de 40 minutos sobre
un rey de la mitología hindú se proyectó
por primera vez en el cine coronation en
mumbai en 1913 durante los siguientes
años se hicieron muchas más películas
mudas sobre mitología hindú y en 1931 se
estrenó la primera película sonora en la
india
alan jara para que os hagáis una idea la
gente quedó tan fascinada que incluso la
policía tuvo que ir a algunos cines de
mumbai para evitar aplastamientos
incluso antes de que la indias
independizara ya hubo una película india
que ganó la palma de oro en cannes esto
ocurrió en 1946 a partir de aquí es
cuando empezó lo que podríamos llamar la
era de oro del cine indio películas que
hablaban de los problemas de la clase
obrera la sociedad post colonial y el
día a día de los indios en los años 70 y
80 surgieron nuevos géneros como el cine
de acción o el cine negro y en los años
90 encontramos películas más
es más centrada en los valores
familiares y en el costumbrismo
[Música]
en otras palabras que durante el siglo
20 la india consolidó toda una industria
del cine sin embargo había un problema
la industria del cine no estaba
reconocida por el gobierno y esto es muy
importante recordad que hablamos de la
india un país extremadamente
intervencionista no estar en la lista de
industrias reconocidas por el estado
significa que las productoras no podían
pedir préstamos a los bancos ni a
ninguna otra institución financiera ojo
esto no significa que hacer películas
fuera ilegal pero podríamos decir que
estaba en una situación de alegalidad es
decir estaban marginados por todo el
sistema político y económico y diréis
que pasa siempre inexorablemente con
todas las industrias que se ven
obligadas a operar fuera del marco
institucional qué pasa cuando un sector
económico entero está en una posición de
alegalidad pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
los gangster entran en los estudios los
años 90 el crimen organizado tenía un
peso enorme en mumbai
sin embargo quitando el tráfico de
drogas el resto de sus negocios iban de
mal en peor
sin embargo bollywood en una industria
muy rentable a la vez las productoras
necesitaban cada vez más dinero para que
sus películas pudieran competir con
hollywood y así es como los gangsters
entraron en el mundo del cine tal cual
como lo oís muchas de las películas más
exitosas de la india en aquellos tiempos
estuvieron financiadas por la mafia y
como os podéis imaginar hacer negocios
con la mafia siempre termina mal queréis
un ejemplo pues os doy un ejemplo
[Música]
el mafioso de byte abu salem amenaza el
realizador sub guy por los derechos de
distribución en el extranjero de una de
sus películas en este caso la policía
consiguió evitar el intento de los
sicarios de abu salem para que sabéis
una idea de la gravedad de este asunto
el tal abu salem está ahora mismo
condenado a cadena perpetua porque
estuvo envuelto en el atentado de mumbai
en 1993 hablamos de un atentado en el
que murieron más de 257 personas
[Música]
otros cineastas como rancheros and my es
bad y bonita poor recibieron amenazas de
la mafia para que les dieran parte de
sus beneficios y hay un montón de
actores que fueron obligados a actuar en
películas financiadas por la mafia
también hay casos de películas donde los
directores estaban obligados a darle un
papel a una de las amantes del mafioso
de turno por ejemplo en el año 1995 un
director de cine llamado seed y que fue
asesinado porque no quiso darle un papel
protagonista al amante de un gángster
para que os hagáis una idea la relación
entre el cine indio y el crimen
organizado llegó a ser tan importante
que hasta apareció en un papel de
wikileaks se ha filtrado un cable
diplomático de eeuu que dice que
bollywood o acepto dinero negro de
gangsters y políticos para financiarse
pero el auténtico punto de inflexión
llegó en 1997 os acordáis de ti series
el canal de youtube más grande del mundo
pues este canal como su propio nombre
indica pertenece a ti sirios que es uno
de los mayores sellos discográficos y
productoras de la india sus fundadores
pues bien en el año 1997 este hombre
murió de un disparo por uno de los
narcos más famosos de la india dawood
ibrahim este hombre por cierto también
estuvo envuelto en los atentados de 1993
este asesinato supuso todo un impacto en
la sociedad india lo que hasta la fecha
era sólo un secreto a voces paso a ser
una de las prioridades de la política
india así que tras muchas décadas el
gobierno decidió cambiar sus políticas
sobre el fin
huele mucho está confuso con su nuevo
estatus de industria pero espera que el
negocio funcione mejor a partir de ahora
en el año 1998 la industria del cine
consiguió por fin el estatus de
industria formal tanto a nivel federal
como a nivel estatal y esto provocó un
cambio radical en la forma de hacer
películas en el año 2000 la ley de
desarrollo industrial bancario permitió
que las productoras pudieran recibir
préstamos de bancos y de empresas y de
repente la economía formal empezó a
financiar películas por ejemplo el
gigante de las telecomunicaciones india
reliance o la productora de televisión
itv empezaron a producir sus propias
películas y poco a poco el cine indio
dejó de ser un negocio peligroso y dejó
de depender de las mafias no obstante
aún hoy en día quedan retazos de ese
pasado tan oscuro por ejemplo en 2015
arrestaron a 10 mafiosos del clan de
rabbit bujari por intento de extorsión
al cineasta majes bat pero vale ya fin
de esta historia ya hemos visto como el
cine indio se ha convertido en una
industria importante sin embargo todavía
no hemos respondido a la pregunta más
importante de este vídeo
pues tranquilos porque ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
porque el cine indio es tan popular lo
hemos dicho al principio el término
bollywood se refiere únicamente a las
películas en hindi pero hay muchos otros
bollywood y muchas veces pueden hacer
incluso más películas que el bollywood
original por ejemplo en el año 2012 se
produjeron 262 películas en tamil que es
el idioma que hablan en ciudades como
chennai y solo 221 en hindi por ejemplo
las películas en idioma de lugo están
creciendo una barbaridad en los últimos
años sin embargo todas estas diferentes
industrias del cine tienen algo en común
todas ellas empezaron a crecer como la
espuma cuando el gobierno reconoció el
cine como una industria
en tan solo diez años el número de
películas certificadas en la india se ha
duplicado en 2009 se produjeron mil 279
películas y en 2019 hablamos de 2.412
además las películas han mejorado mucho
tanto en calidad como en presupuesto
todo esto también significa que ahora es
rentable producir películas en otros
idiomas regionales mucho más
minoritarios como puedan ser en la gam
es el manipule y el chhattisgarh pero
mientras los idiomas regionales siguen
siendo muy importantes las películas en
hindi están ganando cada vez más cuota
de mercado
[Música]
2009 las películas de bollywood suponían
el 18 por ciento de toda la producción
nacional y el 19 por ciento de los
ingresos una década más tarde suponen el
21 por ciento de la producción en
términos económicos bollywood es decir
las películas en hindi hoy en día
representan el 40 por ciento de los
ingresos totales del cine el resto de
idiomas regionales suponen el 47 por
ciento y sólo el 13 por ciento
corresponde al cine internacional donde
se encuentra entre otros muchos cines el
cine de eeuu y aquí viene la pregunta
porque hollywood no puede competir con
el cine y dio en la india y la respuesta
es compleja pero tranquilos porque os la
vamos a dar
la primera razón es la censura tanto las
películas internacionales como las
películas indias tienen que pasar por
los filtros de censura pero a diferencia
de otros países la censura india es
totalmente impredecible porque pues
porque depende del gobierno de turno es
decir que las reglas pueden cambiar cada
cuatro años por ejemplo hubo una época
donde el sexo estaba prohibido es decir
que cada vez que había una escena
erótica aparecían flores en la pantalla
tal cual como lois incluso tienen memes
con esas imágenes os acordáis de esa
escena del titanic donde aparece kate
winslet desnuda pues los indios no la
pudieron ver hoy en día sin embargo las
reglas están más centradas en asuntos de
geopolítica y eso explica que en 2018
todas las escenas donde sale un mapa de
cachemira en la película misión
imposible 4 fueran censuradas por
supuesto si eres un productor de
bollywood te aseguras de que tus
películas no tengan escenas censurables
pero muchas películas de hollywood
terminan proyectándose mutiladas sin
muchas escenas que son cruciales para
entender la trama
pero esperad un momento porque esta no
es la única razón
[Música]
veréis en la mayor parte de los países
incluido españa las entradas del cine
tienen el mismo precio
independientemente de la película que
vayamos a ver pues bien en la india es
totalmente distinto los precios de las
entradas son dinámicos es decir que no
pagas lo mismo si ves una película
extranjera que si ves una película local
es más el precio de una entrada puede
variar dependiendo del asiento que
escojas la hora en la que vayas a ver la
película o incluso el mes pero atentos
porque hay una tercera razón como os
hemos dicho en la india hay muchos
idiomas regionales muchos de ellos son
muy distintos entre ellos es decir que
si quieres entrar en el mercado indio no
basta con doblar tu película lind y
tendrás que doblarla como mínimo a los
26 idiomas regionales más importantes en
otras palabras que solo es rentable
invertir en doblaje para grandes
superproducciones y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando ahora mismo si el cine
indio es tan popular seguramente será un
negocio gigantesco verdad pues lo cierto
es que no
por ejemplo en el año 2019 toda la
industria genera unos ingresos de 13 mil
a 300 millones de dólares y diréis esto
es mucho o es poco pues por hacer una
comparación solo la última película de
la saga de los vengadores ha generado
unos ingresos de casi 2 mil 800 millones
de dólares es más según varias
estimaciones el cine indio da trabajo a
sólo 200 mil personas y aquí es donde
llega la parte más contraintuitiva de
esta historia seguramente muchos
pensaréis que a los indios les encanta
ir al cine verdad pues no exactamente la
india tiene una ratio de 65 pantallas de
cine por cada millón de habitantes por
supuesto este número varía dependiendo
de la región pero para que os hagáis una
idea en china tienen 23 pantallas por
cada millón de habitantes y en eeuu
hablamos de 126
además la piratería es un problema muy
serio en la india se estima que genera
unas pérdidas en la industria de más de
260 millones de dólares al año además
aunque las entradas de cine son cada vez
más caras el precio sigue siendo mucho
más bajo que en otras partes del mundo
por supuesto todos estos datos están
cambiando a medida que crece en las
plataformas online de vídeo bajo demanda
como netflix y tantas otras ahora bien
las salas de cine no son la única vía de
ingresos del cine indio si alguna vez
habéis visto una película de bollywood
ya sabéis que la música y los bailes son
muy pero que muy importantes y por eso
una parte muy importante del negocio del
cine viene de los derechos musicales ahí
es donde entran empresas como ti series
y music o sony music
de hecho muchas veces se utilizan los
ingresos de la música como capital
semilla para nuevas películas todo esto
explica por qué youtube es tan
importante para bollywood les sirven
para promocionar su música y por eso el
canal de ti series es el canal más
grande del mundo mucho más grande que el
del mismísimo pedí pero bueno ya hemos
hablado de la parte económica de esta
historia ahora vamos a ver el lado
político porque creedme hay un lado muy
político en esta historia ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
3 de bollywood hacia el mundo os voy a
hacer una pregunta habéis visto alguna
vez una película india lo más probable
es que la respuesta sea un rotundo no y
por eso muchos pensaréis que el cine
indio está pensado únicamente para el
consumo doméstico verdad error craso
error por ejemplo a los rusos les
encanta el cine de bollywood tal cual
como lo oís durante los años 50 el hielo
unión soviética- compartían el misma
aversión hacia occidente y así es como
empezó una bonita amistad entre
bollywood y rusia
[Música]
en el año 1951 particular fue la primera
película proyectada en salas soviéticas
esta película contaba la historia de la
hambruna de bengala de 1943 y estaba
producida por ipta que era un grupo
teatral de izquierdas incluso en 1954 se
llegó a hacer una producción in 27 k
llamada paredes desde entonces más de
300 películas indias se proyectaron en
salas soviéticas hasta el fin del
comunismo
desde entonces la audiencia de estas
películas han seguido creciendo y ahora
se estima que entre 20 millones y 60
millones de rusos de películas indias
todos los años
el romance de rusia con caja por
continúa hoy en día 29 años después de
su muerte e incluso hoy en día en la
rusia de vladimir putin la televisión
estatal tomás me ofrece películas de
bollywood la película aguará del actor
rack kapur fue todo un éxito en los años
60 y todavía lo es hoy en día entre los
rusos todo un clásico la típica película
nostálgica que todo el mundo ha visto
alguna vez en rusia pero no sólo
hablamos de este país como sabéis hay
una enorme diáspora india en todo el
mundo y muchas películas están dirigidas
para ese público por ejemplo en los años
90 la película de walt de luján ya le
hai en que contaba la historia de una
familia india que vivían reino unido
esta película fue tal exitazo que
incluso recibió un premio de la
autoridad de turismo británico por
promover el turismo en la india incluso
cuando el mismísimo barack obama visitó
la india en 2015 intento imitar un
diálogo de esta película
señorita puede poner
de hecho me
y ahora a mí
sin embargo la mayor estrella
internacional de bollywood hoy en día es
el actor
dukan y creedme este señor no es famoso
únicamente en la india atentos a las
estrellas de bollywood se dirigen a
marruecos todo un comité de estrellas
indias incluyendo sarukhán fueron al
festival internacional de cine de
marrakech y fueron recibidos por
montones de fans en esta ceremonia el
rey marroquí mohamed sexto le dio una
estrella de oro que es una especie de
condecoración nacional al mismísimo
sarukhán y ya se lo que estará pensando
alguno si seguís visual política desde
hace tiempo ya sabéis que los musulmanes
en la india son una de las minorías más
maltratadas del país los hinduistas y
los musulmanes no se llevan exactamente
bien sin embargo cuando hablamos de cine
en la historia es totalmente distinta
del mundo árabe hay canales enteros como
por ejemplo si a flan que se dedican a
retransmitir en exclusiva películas de
bollywood es más os acordáis de ese
actor del que os acabamos de hablar
sarukhán pues mira
de esta ahora la roca es nombrado como
embajador de la marca de dubai pero esto
no estuvo en wikileaks se han llegado a
filtrar cables diplomáticos donde eeuu
sugiere utilizar a actores indios en
estrategias antiterroristas por lo visto
las películas indias son terriblemente
conocidas en países como afganistán e
incluso durante los tiempos de los
talibanes existían redes de contrabando
de dvds con películas de bollywood pero
esperado un momento porque todavía falta
la guinda del pastel cuál es el mercado
emergente por antonomasia exacto china
de nuevo si sois veteranos seguidores de
visual política ya sabéis que las
relaciones entre india y china son cada
vez peores incluso es frecuente ver
pequeñas escaramuzas en la frontera de
china con la india eso ya os hemos
hablado en un vídeo que os dejo en la
descripción sin embargo cuando hablamos
de cine la historia es totalmente
distinta
[Música]
están ya les está cerca de lograr los
150 millones de dólares en la taquilla
china tang al es un drama sobre lucha
libre protagonizado por el actor
amir khan se estrenó en nada menos que 9
mil salas de cine chinas este éxito se
debe en parte a que los productores
hicieron una enorme campaña de marketing
en este país unos años más tarde la
película sigue el superstar consigue
recaudar más dinero en china que el
último yeray de la saga star wars
[Música]
en otras palabras que el cine indio está
compitiendo mano a mano con el cine
estadounidense en uno de los mercados
más importantes del mundo así que ahora
la pregunta es para vosotros veremos
algún día películas indias dobladas al
inglés o al español puede el cine indio
llegar a ser tan influyente como el cine
estadounidense
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual político sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto